the beginning of best weekend ever fall
2016 number one weekend so the plan is
take this weekend go up to Big Bear
we're bringing all our friends shonduras
will be joining us as well we're gonna
play a bunch of nerf games this weekend
is also airsoft con so we're gonna kick
things off by first going to airsoft con
hopefully it all goes smoothly POV I
[Music]
want to meet you guys my own life okay I
feel like you feel excited I'm super
excited we just got back in airsoft calm
then we're gonna go up to Big Bear or
spend a weekend playing games it's gonna
be great waiting for everyone to get
here and hopefully we can leave them
about five minutes Shawn I don't I can't
move I don't know how to walk let me
gonna help you man
you just gotta stand on this and
everything is better yeah are you
excited
dude I'm so excited I can't I'm so
excited than the new building me oh yeah
I'll be sick well let's start a third
channel it's just like our combined
footage all right we are leaving we're
leaving happening we're going to Big
Bear
[Music]
I get to go to YouTube every month I'm
new to YouTube I'm really excited to be
in it they invited me in it but the
bummer is it's right during the middle
of our awesome trip so I have to take
like a three-hour uber ride to rewind
film a couple things and then three our
uber ride back and I just really hope I
get a chill uber writer so I get to
sleep in the backseat don't wake up and
have a mic breathing down my neck at
five stars
I wonder if overing around all night
sleeping the back seat would be cheaper
than renting a hotel and then we're on
the Sun here to motorcycle gang come in
hot three two there's one
[Music]
yep holy crap pingas con compound oh
it's nice be really fun to reach our
neighbors gonna hate us I was waiting
for Brandon to get here even though he's
got a Tesla there's something way more
valuable in the back huh yes where is it
awesomest it's right here oh you're
really taking Brandon why you do this
yeah this is gonna be multiple trips
guys yeah no I'm done before but this
car nothing to completely take your
weight off so we'll spin and put your
weight back on yeah Oh nobody do like a
glasses on my head this repair guy
showed up on a Segway and I'm definitely
not supposed to get on it but
till I got on it I'll put it back is it
everything you could have hoped it could
be yeah it's pretty cool it's you have
you've been out back
[Music]
yeah cool
[Applause]
[Music]
split the teams come in do outside
background breaching into the house you
know casual team versus team in a
mansion nerf uh you know feeling that
the usual casual what's going on right
now I am trying to figure out absolutely
that 8:00 in the morning side when you
leave here like 5:30 in the morning
there's not even a burrs than Big Bear
I'm like double phoning that's how
stressed out I found a limousine service
that will take me but that's like super
expensive and I don't want a little
obscene dried what happens if you don't
make it back there YouTube's really mad
at me because they like have a spot menu
to rewind I just look irresponsible he's
bad I'm gonna figure it out I'm gonna
get there even if I have to like
hitchhike do you guys think for
Halloween I should go with Sean and Sean
should go as me right look at this he
just darkens his hair my hair and then I
just like light in my hair and then I
just act really nice and smart all the
time and he just skateboards around
actually yes know what's going on get
closer so our heads are like the same
size good there's no difference it looks
like we just took a selfie
that's Halloween coming soon
[Music]
let me tell you a tale about a whale
kind of situation it's 6:30 in the
morning remember how I told you guys I
needed to get to LA I wasn't sure how it
was gonna happen
absolutely that ate the Morningside when
you leave here like 5:30
there's not even a Berzin big bear we
figured it out I'm taking a helicopter
it's not scared there it's a buddy of
mine he knows I'll fly helicopters so
this is kind of what it looks like right
now everybody's asleep see what happens
on the journey I've never really just
taken a helicopter somewhere for no
reason it should be pretty cool if
you're off all along I'll be on my
channel and then I'll be back here with
you guys in like a couple hours BRB all
right day two morning eating everybody
and Sam made a bacon weave it's not
often I get to exercise my bacon cooking
skills for groups but when I do the
bacon weave is definitely the way to go
because it creates these perfect little
bite sized chunks house fast sunny
morning and we are finally all up it's
about 9:00 that's complete lights 1:00
p.m. I feel like we're off to a great
Sunday start this is the exact way
Sunday's should start I feel man look at
these leaves this is like perfect autumn
weather here we don't get to senility
[Music]
we work you if you do this I will also
I'll switch and I'll be the clown to
like that's the idea the original idea
was that we're gonna like switch after a
couple rounds for sure just because if
we try to switch every round it would
take forever yeah and yep yeah like I
love the rain I think it's kind of
probably gonna be a little sporadic
we're gonna shoot it's gonna be fun and
that's all that's gonna be it's gonna be
a little wet grant bring it bring it
these guys are about to do some airsoft
clown I'm not participating so I'm just
rolling around on the wheel that's a
pretty sweet gun there Sam yeah Hank
that yourself yeah we have so many nerf
guns floating around the office that
it's hard to figure out whose is whose
and nice to make a difference Pro nerf
players bling out their gun I made mine
gold and then made the mag to match for
the best
that's what's all about oh man
nikka yeah how's his weekend also far as
it's been a thong yeah it's been great
you know I thought the rain would really
kind of mess things up here in the
middle today we actually ended up
shooting in the rain and everything
looks really cinematic because of it I'm
hitting the point where I don't know how
much more nerf I can handle for me it's
literally nerf or nothing I was on the
winning team like pulling I wasn't a
winning team for both sides of it so uh
I had a pretty good time that's the
first day here at the Big Bear mansion
it is raining yet again apparently it
was raining and thundering back into
downtown LA so maybe this whole entire
tribe back won't be so easy
I think it's like Shawn Shawn you're
back what happened bro dude my uber
driver was awesome like we straight up
sup two different times I bought him a
strawberry milk like we had a good time
you know it was supposed to be like two
hours and 20 minutes but he was really
nervous going to the wine nice we kept
like pull you over letting cars past so
it was like an extra hour and a half
it's okay because we had a road trip was
like we became but see that were our
uber road right yeah and I'm okay with
it
okay that is good all right have some
Martinelli's for the road it was a
time-honored tradition I thought you're
like shaking smashing ball
you're gonna burp so I get you to read
[Music]
[Applause]
wait wait wait hey thanks for the ride
guys
no bro
[Music]